these people have traveled here from all
over Germany to demonstrate for clean
energy people in many areas want to put
a stop to fracking they're afraid of the
technology and they're doing all they
can to block its use we think it's
morally unacceptable to do this just to
turn a quick profit to make permanent
changes to things here on earth and
possibly destroy them in the process
if they start fracking here then they'll
be pumping chemicals into the earth they
always say they'll come back out again
but I'm not so sure if they do it I
think our groundwater will suffer will
no longer be able to drink clean water
as we can now and that really worries me
but jobs are scarce here in
mecklenburg-vorpommern on the baltic
coast and the state's infrastructure
leaves a lot to be desired drilling rigs
loom just outside the town of Zod the
operators claim they'll help bring in
much-needed income there's oil some
three kilometres below the surface here
though it will take years to bring it up
on a major scale the project is
currently just in the test phase
drinking water here doesn't come from
depths below 65 meters our drill hole
will be up to 2,700 metres deep and will
traverse several hundred litres of
totally leak-proof salt layers in other
words it will pose no danger to drinking
water just think fossa just eat kinda go
far
fracking is the use of hydraulic methods
to mine for petroleum or natural gas the
process which employs various chemicals
involves pumping water at extreme
pressures beneath the surface where it
fractures deep layers of rock
the German Canadian company CEP has
acquired the rights to exploit resources
here
the firm's founders have collected
around 100 million euros so far to
investigate known oil reserves in
eastern Germany this isn't the Gulf of
Mexico the oil in this region is older
we know that we also of course have
access to all of the experience that
we've gained in the past in this field
and we're using it it's not very
difficult to assess the risks it's da
Beauty environmental activists from
Greenpeace don't agree and have been
keeping a close eye on CEP is test site
for months the organization's experts
say that for many reasons fracking here
is completely irresponsible busyness is
a coup we think that there's a risk of
uncontrolled oil and toxic chemical
pollution in this area which relies on
tourism we also believe there's a risk
that fracking could provoke tremors or
earthquakes and finally we think there's
a risk that the substance is acquired
using this process will not be handled
professionally or appropriately Medina
Oscar furnished often needs architect
when [ __ ] Google can accompany really
drill for oil in the middle of a tourist
area on the Baltic coast the state
government is hoping for tax income
generated by oil CEP is convinced that
fracking has a future in
mecklenburg-vorpommern it estimates the
state harbors around 18 billion euros in
oil reserves
this is best to oversee that place this
is the best oil in the world it's the
same quality as Brent crude back during
the days of the former East Germany oil
from this area was exported to Russia
where they used it in the space industry
it's a top quality product there's
nothing better
speaking quality better could be even if
it is the best oil in the world the
dangers that getting it out pose are
completely disproportionate to what
stands to be gained we need to take a
different tack to think about how we
could be saving energy rather than just
using more of it just saying great
here's lots more oil let's burn it
people Lauder Hippolytus the method is
highly controversial at the political
level and as it stands fracking is still
not permitted in Germany and if these
activists have their way it never will
be